[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time I'm R
what I don't know why I said I started
saying I before I'm Rusty is it's this
new year this is the first one we
recorded this is not a good sign and
I'm new this year I'm link no no no
explain what all along no you felt bad
about starting it and then you were like
well I got to say it the right way yeah
yeah yeah exactly that's what that's
what went through my my I I was so ready
to say my part that I was like I'm link
and then as I heard myself say I'm I was
like oh well this is appropriate this is
appropriate because that was the first
thing I wanted to talk about is what I
screwed up I am link what I screwed up
um in front of a
a different
audience last night yeah right I uh you
know me I don't like I don't I don't
like to screw things up you know it's to
a pathological
Point uh maybe was growing up in a
family where screwing up wasn't well
tolerated yeah I I I didn't want to I
didn't want to bring it up unless you
wanted to bring it up uh but since you
want to talk about it I did bring it up
in
moment yeah but while I was still on
stage okay let's start at the beginning
CU but it's my
fault so we had the privilege and honor
of um presenting at the 75th MH emys not
the real emies let's be real I mean
they're real emmies but it was the
creative arts emies it wasn't the the
main emies that you see on Prime Time
television we made the mistake of
thinking that it was a lesser Emy just
because it wasn't televised it was still
recorded and it's still going to be
broadcast it is televised somewhere like
FXX or something um but the moment we
showed up I mean we had to wear tuxes
the reason we didn't think it was as big
of a deal as it was is because we were
both confused yeah because like 12 or 13
years ago I don't even think we lived in
La at the time we had just moved here we
were asked to MC to host
some Emy thing that was over there at
the uh the Dolby Theater or something
right we host and we thought that that
was the creative arts emmies and we I
don't even remember anything about that
we hosted the whole thing we were trying
to be funny I'm sure we were somewhat
annoying they were giving out emies
there too but it was yeah that was less
than this cuz the moment we showed up in
our tuxes cuz we were told to wear tuxes
I mean everybody was I mean this was
this is a much bigger deal than I had
realized the queer eye guys were were
there uh got to meet Tim Robinson was
very excited about that and then he won
the first award which was a short form
comedy so Olivia rup Paul Kiki Palmer
you know there's like recognizable
celebs there the night before was the
scripted emies that aren't in the
televised version and the night that we
were there was the unscripted emies that
just don't make it in the televis
version cuz everything can't make it so
and and then they see us and we're
literally in the center on the front row
yeah I was like how did we get these
seats why why did why did we get these
seat I told Christy this morning I was
like this is much bigger deal than we
realized and I actually started to get
nervous and um I wasn't I was actually
proud of myself for not being nervous in
the like weeks leading up to it because
a lot of times when you're about to do
something that's out of your comfort
zone in front of a group of people
that you know there's a little bit of a
chip on the shoulder of a YouTuber going
into that environment that you're kind
of thinking like oh YouTuber and so I
was like but you know what I'm actually
feeling good about it because I'm not
really concerned about what these people
think about me also not realizing that
it would be the crowd that it was Carol
Bernett Carol Bernett was on the front
row Seated on the front row like five
seats down from us and the first person
who came out was Jeff prop Jeff prop
started the whole show oh man I love me
some Jeff propes I I got to meet me Jeff
propes we got to get him on uh good
mythical morning yes got to make that
work and they then it was like oh crap
this is um this is this is a this is a
thing and they had sent us the script
it's a big stage this is a full
production this is like steady cams
roaming in front of us um I'm like act
like you are meant to be here they sent
us the script ahead of time and uh I was
like this is a pretty good script and I
just made one change I I exchange one
joke mhm and felt pretty good about it
they did put us to hours and 20 minutes
2 hours and 20 minutes into the show and
it was a 2 hour and 30 minute show so
that took some of the pressure off CU on
any of these shows by the time you get
to the second hour or past that people
just kind of want to get to the
Afterparty yeah and so I was the one
that was supposed to start and I had a
teleprompter which everybody I I well
I'm just saying that in my mind having a
teleprompter is the reason for why I
said the thing that I said but which I
told you ahead of time when you were
asking me to like make some changes or
like you want to change this and I was
like I'm just going to stick to the
teleprompter because that's how I
maintain my composure in situations like
this it's like I don't I don't go off
prompter and uh because it was like
three lines and then you're done right
three lines from me three lines from you
and we're done yeah and the first line
was in celebration of the 75th EMS or
something like that and I literally said
in celebration of the 75th EMS and and
you realized it as you said it well
because I'm looking at the thing and I'm
like in celebration of
75 IM and I said and so you gave me a
moment to say like you were like you
you've stuttered you sputtered a little
bit well I was thinking it something
clever to say and you
said I can't remember what I said you
said no I said 75th I said 75th and you
said yeah you should probably say 75th
what I would have said I thought I said
was I thought what I said was you can
you can that's that's not the way you
say it or you I thought you say you
should probably say 75th or something
like that I don't know we'll watch it
back on
FXX but what I thought about after it
had happened was what I should have said
is I should have said 75th yes it's the
new
75th and I would have gotten some
laughs at least I acknowledged that you
said and then we went on to deliver
these pre-written jokes that I could
have said something funnier too got a
couple of
laughs uh but then we were in between
Awards I made a joke about Betty White
being white you did but in celebration
of the technological advancement of
color television that was the best joke
um but in between the awards because we
gave out two Awards while they were
showing the Montage of the
nominees um it got dark and you leaned
over to me and you said yeah 75 really
that's not what I said as if that's not
what as if I wasn't already drowning in
shame okay my best friend leans over and
says 75 really okay here's what really
happened I was drowning in shame up
there the lights go down your boy was
drowning in
shame I and you piled on I could tell
that you were not happy with yourself
because you were standing there
motionless just looking into nothing you
were looking looking inside of your
brain I had one thing I had one thing to
do say 75th this is the third word the
thing that I've always said when I say
75th yeah I mean I've never said
75th it's like billbo B
11 110th I'm a hobit there so many good
jokes like if I had that Small Wonder
thing where she could like pause time or
go back I don't know if I had the ring
where you could go back in time there's
so many things that I could say I'm a
hobbit of course I could just say 75th
listen I just got back from New Zealand
the ring makes you invisible it does not
make you go back in time yeah yeah I'm
I'm talking about a different ring
there's one ring r no no no R them all
I'm talking about a ring that takes you
back in time to then say are separate
thing about being a hobbit um but what I
said so I knew that you were kind of
stewing or in in shame and so you wanted
to rub it a little bit no I was trying
to make you feel better but I had saying
I had to say something what I said was
that's not what I remember I mean and of
course you know the crowd is still out
there everybody that's thinking about
that of course only thinking about 75th
that's the only thing they're thinking
about so yeah I lean over to you and I'm
like 75th huh that's what I said 75 huh
oh that's better I mean it was I I'll
let you off easy man I was like man you
really screwed the pooch man you made
made us both look stupid it doesn't
matter it doesn't matter it it didn't
matter to me it didn't matter to me cuz
it wasn't me no I
I it was fine man and but I knew there
wasn't anything I could say that would
make you feel better in that moment
because the lights were about to come up
and we're about to give an award well
the thing that I so the thing that I
regretted wasn't necessarily saying 75 I
mean obviously that was the thing that
was the error it was in retrospect not
then having the funny thing to say about
screwing up right people I mean um
what's her
name uh you don't even remember her name
see she screwed up too the one that said
telion yeah she said teion but then she
said something funny no she said
television and she talked about the
authenticity of reality television or
something and said that she was kind of
making a point right right um anyway I
felt bad for I really don't I don't I
mean in you recovered man you said your
jokes yeah yeah yeah we we got out of it
I'm just saying that it was as I
observed myself and how I reacted in
that situation realizing that I was
caring more about this than anyone else
was caring everybody who was there first
of all who was left let's be honest Tim
Robinson had gone home I looked down
there because he was the one I was
really worried about he was gone he was
gone um
so many people had left two hours and 20
minutes car Bernett was still there
Carol Bernett was there but she's 90
yeah she probably didn't hear
me you know so I I think uh you
shouldn't beat yourself up over it it
was a it was an exercise in uh humility
but also in the just the the much better
to mess that up than to mess the joke up
that would have been much worse that's
what that's what my wonderful wife's
told told me
she said wies wies you're still doing it
man yeah yeah yeah well I new
development 2024 I've got two wives now
oh see now you're recovering with E look
you see how polyam if I was that funny
last night if I could make a polygamy
joke it wouldn't have mattered uh when I
was talking to Jesse she was like well
when you said you screwed up I thought
maybe you had like said the wrong name
when you open the envelope or you
screwed a joke up but you just screwed
up 75 come on give yourself a break it
is a mistake that no one would ever make
because how could you like where that
where does that come from you read you
read 75 and then the th was on the next
line or something no no no the only way
one can make that joke make that mistake
is by reading the word SE the the number
75 it wasn't 75th it was written out 75
th and so in my brain I got to 75 and
just saw so I was just like the
75 yeah you you read it as literal as
possible I was too committed to sticking
to the prompt I told you man but I
normally do better when I stick to the
prompter but apparently you can't stick
so tightly to the prompter that you
don't see the th not in 2024 man yeah so
next time they invite us if they do to
the emies
if they don't I'm not gonna it be right
right yeah man
listen listen let me just let mean look
at me look at
me I want to get this hair off your eyes
I thought you about to do some sort of
uh you got a hair right there push that
back I was like you thought I was going
to some kind of magic to make me not
feel shame me look at me I want you to
let me let me gra back your neck I want
you to know that you are
loved and you are respect
I'm just saying next time and you are
you are normally composed next time you
were composed I shamed myself in that
way you you didn't lose compos what I
would ask of you as a best friend is
just to be like hey nobody cares or just
or like it's going to be okay man 75 huh
I thought that was I thought I was that
make repeat the thing that I just the
only thing that I'm thinking right now
is 75 75 why did you say 75 and then
your buddy leans over and says 75
huh I'm sorry man I was I was really
just thinking yeah I need to say
something and it's uh sometimes it's
better anything at all man I did I
honestly didn't realize that I made it
worse I'm
sorry yeah well I'm okay
now it was the first thing I thought
about when I woke up though 7 literally
like the like as your brain is Awakening
to the world and you're beginning to
orient to the day like I just saw
75 and that's me that's my problem not
just the screw up but the fact that that
would be the first thing that I think
about if if if the shoe was on the other
foot um I feel like uh it would have
been you know better for everybody cuz I
put my foot in my mouth all the time and
you're always ready to take it out right
see now see I didn't I didn't that's
what I I failed you in not saying
something funnier than what I said was a
setup for you and you failed that's you
should be feeling sh I did say something
but I'm sorry that I didn't say
something better if you were me in that
moment you would have said something
better but I would have been the butt of
the
joke
um well and that and I and you know
what that would that would have been the
best for comedy I just don't I see I
didn't have the instinct to
publicly well next time really go for
the just be ready man I make mistakes
too it's tough you got to be ready for
mean to make mistakes yeah I make them
quite a bit yeah you need to stay in
your lane though I'm the mistake maker
yeah see that's not fair n i don't it's
not
fair are you done thinking about it
now is my year of mistakes
oh just so you know do you feel like you
can put this behind you you can
integrate this in a way you know I was
um I was a bit preoccupied with the fact
that I had gotten Clippers Lakers
tickets for me and my family that I had
secured before we ever got this
gig and I didn't really understand that
we were going to be too even though it
was in the it was in the information
that Jenna that you sent ahead of time
but ID failed to really read all that uh
and didn't realize that we were going to
be giving our presentation like after
the game had been going for an hour
thankfully it was literally in the
peacock theater which is right next to
the crypto.com arena so it was just like
walking over but I was thinking about
man I paid all this money for these
tickets for this Clippers Lakers game
and I'm excited about it um and then as
I was getting changed after 75 and I was
walking over I was like but you know
what I'm going to watch my clippers take
out the Lakers because you know that's
what they're going to do and did they
they lost oh so it was like L upon l oh
it was a Double L but you and you pulled
like a reverse James Bond you like had a
duffel bag and you went into the
bathroom in a tux and you came out in
like LA Clippers gear I did I did and
left me with your bag see that's a
pretty good friend I do appreciate make
I carried your Duff bag cared my duffel
bag what did you do at that party with
it uh I like a big fanny pack No I gave
it to somebody to put in the car oh good
yeah so I I ped it off pretty much
immediately I feel like you could Rock a
Duff yeah I had a whole bit um where's
Rhett oh he he's he's deflated in this
duffel did you see the 75 no that was
pretty good that was pretty good
completely you should have said thater I
rolled him up after he deflated and I
put him in his T yeah I appreciate you
holding my bag oh God that almost makes
up for rubbing it in in the moment I
didn't rub it I didn't wasn't trying to
rub it in okay listen I if it will make
you feel better I had some big fails
on my epic New Zealand trip that I want
to tell you about okay right after we
tell you to go to mythical.com yes and
check out this amazing collection you
know what time it is it's the time to
look at a t-shirt another t-shirt a
hoodie sweatpants trucker hat we got
longle there's a whole freaking
Ensemble over there
sweaties you'll look good and you'll be
comfy it's going to be great for you you
know what time it is collection check it
out at mythical.com
ear biscuits is brought to you by better
help better help in this particular ad
is encouraging us to think about New
Year's resolutions in the in the other
direction like to be even more positive
I I like this like a new thinking the
opposite of new year new you instead
thinking about your life in terms of
where you're crushing like where
something's going well and how you can
build on that I like that I like this
too like for me I'm an organizer but
there's always something else that I can
organize I'm going to get even better at
that a better organizer yeah maybe you
finally organize one part of your space
and you want to tackle another or maybe
you're taking your supplements every
morning and now you want to actually eat
breakfast too okay therapy will help you
find your strengths so you can ditch the
extreme resolutions and make changes
that really stick you know we're huge
advocates for therapy and want it to be
accessible to everyone so if you're
thinking of starting therapy give better
help a try it's entirely online designed
to be convenient flexible and suited to
your schedule just fill out a brief
questionnaire to get matched with the
licensed therapist and switch therapist
anytime for no additional charge
celebrate the progress you've made visit
betterhelp.com
today to get 10% off your first month
that's better help HP
/ar ear biscus is supported by Rosetta
Stone you know sometimes you travel to
other countries link like you just
traveled to New Zealand and sometimes um
you need help understanding the people
in that country well a lot of them speak
English oh okay well maybe this doesn't
apply as much but B accent is so strong
that it sounds like another language in
comes Rosetta Stone not exactly it's not
for accents I mean it's for accents
within languages just let me stick with
the copy right Rosetta Stone is the most
trusted language learning program
available on desktop or is an app that
truly immerses you in the language you
want to learn they've used trusted
experts for 30 years with millions of
users and 25 languages offered some of
which include Spanish French German
Korean Chinese Japanese Dutch and Arabic
I don't see New Zealand dis on there no
but probably because that's English uh
or mayori Rosetta immerses you in many
ways there are no English translations
so you really learn to speak listen and
think in that language and with their
built-in true accent feature that gives
you feedback on your pronunciation
you'll be speaking like a pro in no time
plus it's an amazing value a lifetime
membership has all 25 languages for any
and all trips or language needs in life
a
$399 program but with our code you can
get it for just
$199 don't put off learning that
language there's no better time than
right now to get started for a very
limited time you can get Rosetta Stone's
lifetime membership for 50% off that's
50% off for unlimited access to 25
language courses for the rest of your
life redeem your 50% off at
rosettastone.com
today I've been planning this trip to
New Zealand for over a year you know
during the pandemic we were rewatching
all of the Lord of the Rings extended
DVD behind the scenes I don't know hours
and hours hours of uh content and just
getting back into realizing that you
know what Middle Earth exists it's a
place called New
Zealand where's old Zealand I don't know
was there ever a Zealand it had to be
like I was there I was there in New
Zealand this whole time and no one ever
talked about the old one it's got to be
like this this one's definitely better
this is an improvement on the other one
is Zealand just another word for Britain
because all their money has the Queen on
it maybe it was
Sealand and then New Zealand yeah let's
just conjecture at length about that CU
we don't know we're not going to figure
it out it makes sense of Sealand uh it's
a fresh place I will say that it's
totally worthy of being
new beautiful
huh most beautiful place on Earth uh
that's what they say it is it is
extremely
easy on the eyes Everywhere You Look So
we had I mean the first thing that we
booked over a year in advance was
visiting hobbiton it's Middle Earth that
hobbiton is literally
there like well the place where they I
mean the place where they made the movie
not the place where Jr talking like but
it in its in its entirety like when you
like that shot of hobbiton has all the
homes yes that's all completely Inta
yeah well they tore it all down after
the Lord of the Rings production and
then took everything
out uh but then when they made The
Hobbit movies they rebuilt the entire
thing on the same piece of sheep
farmland and then the the guy who owned
the land I don't know whose idea it was
but they they hatched this idea that say
Hey listen let's not make the mistake of
tearing this down again right yeah like
now we're going to this is going to be a
permanent fixture more money than sheep
for sure it's the you know how when you
go if you have the privilege of going to
Walt Disneyland or world or any of the
Disney places you're struck by how the
attention to detail everywhere like
going from ride to ride and attraction
to attraction is not just about the
attraction is being amazing but the
entire experience is curated it's not
six all the way no all the way down to
like the trash cans and the smell in the
air and like the The Mulch underneath
the bushes that you can't can't see this
was the only experience I've been to
where I bought a ticket and it topped
that like the attention to detail you
felt like you were there it was amazing
and then um are there Hobbits there are
no Hobbits running around it's they're
too tasteful for that okay that were all
the hobbits are I don't know they're
they don't like to leave I don't know
where they didn't tell me where they
were but they weren't there okay and
they had they spaced out the tour groups
well well enough that like you could see
people on the other you know at
different spots but like it wasn't you
went through in a in a group with a
guide and it was so it was very uh
walking yeah walking you're walking
right up to Hobbit holes all around the
thing and you may be choosing to take a
picture of every single Hobbit Hole like
my wife did I on the other hand just
took a picture of one maybe two Hobbit
holes and then I looked at all the rest
of them with my eyes and enjoyed it but
I chose not to pick that fight because
the main thing about being on a family
trip is knowing what battles to choose
and basically if you can choose none
that's success and I was pretty good at
that you know didn't impact my
experience and I I realized I wasn't
going to go into dad mode and like look
at that stop taking pictures and do this
you know I didn't I was
not in charge of my family
experience once we got there the tour
guy they had their own choices to make
with their own phones and with and and
they could listen to the tour guy and do
whatever they wanted that unlocked a lot
of happiness for me to abdicate all of
my responsibilities as a dad to make
sure that anyone else was having a good
time smart it may sound selfish but hey
I set this thing up I book the tickets
or I asked someone to book the tickets
or I ask someone to ask someone to book
the tickets but it happened you know
come
on yeah so I did my part everybody
everybody loved hobbiton it was a
highlight and can you when you go into
the now I'm I'm experienced enough of a
filmmaker to know that they didn't shoot
the inside of those Hobbit holes in the
same place they did that on the Sound
Stage you're too smart for me man but
what I do want to know is what's inside
those Hobbit holes um Darkness okay
utter
darkness no furnace what I did Furniture
not know was that they had remade the
last two Hobbit holes um like two months
before we got there this was like fresh
fresh they had remodeled so that you
could go into they split the group in
half and you went into either the proud
foots Hobbit Hole or another Hobbit hole
that was similar but catered to another
family like designed to another family
so you can't go into Bill Bow's thing
cuz they're not going to try to recreate
no you can't go in the Bag End um but
it's it we didn't even know this was
going to happen and then they're like
okay we're going to go into these Hobbit
holes and they it was absolutely Picture
Perfect in there like talk about the
attention to detail then went up like 10
notches like little
furniture beds little bunk beds little
sinks with running water could you get
in the beds uh yeah if you wanted to you
could sit on the bed H you're just like
I mean you're you're just walking around
there's no there's no like Photo there's
no ropes Christie could have taken a
photo of that you in the bed me and her
in the bed
potentially um we didn't do that it it
was super impressive um you made a fart
sound with your hands it's kind of
undermining no no cuz that's me saying
super impressive it you literally did
you did you know yeah again there's a
few things for
2024 couple of wives mistakes and hand
farts what like but you did not know you
were going to do that you know yeah yeah
yeah I did I was like I'm going to wait
for the perfect moment in his story to I
don't think they heard see look how good
are recovering these microphones are
very directional link so I think this
probably but this but but I heard it you
you clap I'm telling I'm telling a story
about the most beautiful thing I've
encountered in the whole year you clas
your hands and hand exactly the right
time you you said picture perfect and I
was like
yep I thought that was good timing it
was it was good timing you have good
instincts but you pures
cost person probably a lot dude the
other thing I decided not to do was look
at the cost okay good and I'm just being
honest I mean once you decide to go to
New Zealand and you're going to you have
to do hobbiton you cannot look at the
cost you know you count the cost of
going to New Zealand and not visiting
hobon that's the cost how many how much
time do you spend at hobon is there a
gift shop is there a restaurant at the
end of the freaking tour you go to the
uh it's not the prancing pony it's the
other one and you get a beer they give
you a beer here okay well and it's got
alcohol in it I'm just I'm thinking
about all the things that they could
have done and and and you can also get a
cider it also has alcohol in it do they
sell fireworks
no no okay uh they don't do that do they
what do they sell they sell like scones
uh hairy feet that you could put on over
your feet lots of um I you know what I
don't know if they sell maps and they
sell a lot of uh models
oh yeah I don't know what I don't know
if they sold hairy feet I I went back to
the
car and waited yeah and your kids stayed
in the yeah cuz I was looking at I was
trying to figure out the next thing
bought something at bought a map she
bought a map um the main thing I want to
talk about though
is I I really wasn't mentally prepared
for the main thing that was going to be
an immersive experience that was
entirely different than anything I've
ever experienced that put me in the
driver's seat of a situation that I was
not prepared for and that was quite
literally getting in the driver's seat
of my rental car and then which was on
the wrong side of the car ex excuse me
for saying it that way on the other side
of the car and then having to drive on
the other side of the roads in over the
course of our entire twoe trip now don't
you think just a little bit that this
might be a recipe for
disaster
Yeah because sometimes you driving on
the right side of the road can be a
recipe for disaster I mean how many
pedestrians have I almost almost hit
almost maimed killed or otherwise
clipped here in America that then like
that you've seen firsthand that then
dm'd us later yeah yeah
uh at least one at least one um many
pedestrians have been taught the lesson
of looking both ways and that is the by
me that is the real risk when when
you're in another country first of all
as a pedestrian being in a country where
they drive on the other side of the road
it's easy to get hit because you look
the wrong way when you cross the street
which also means that it's probably easy
for the hitting to happen in London I
did not ever drive when I visited but as
a pedestrian when I would cross every
street I would look down uh at the
crosswalk and they would have signs
everywhere on the on that on the
pavement and they would say look right
everywhere you looked look right look
right none of that in New Zealand like
no pedestrian look right anywhere now
when I got my rental car I mean you
fresh off the plane you you you flown
for over 11 hours you you're on the
precipice of your wildest dreams coming
true but you're jet lagged and you know
it's it's it's 6:00 a.m. but I don't
know what it's the day before and what
is going on and I get in the car
and I'm in the passenger seat like
literally I've like gotten in the car
completely so you didn't think about
this until that
moment I the thought crossed my mind
mind but then I'm like I should think
about it later you know I'm think about
it later and so the later was when I was
in the passenger seat looking for the
steering wheel CU you know when I went
to
Scotland I it's a little difference in
our personalities here and I knew I was
going to be driving all throughout
Scotland and then I was going to have to
drive all the way from
from the highlands all the way to London
over the course of a few days I and I
was driving a big van like a M like with
your extended
passenger and uh so I watched videos
about like how to like get your brain
ready for for it and even having done
that like you you you prepared I
prepared and I still wasn't prepared and
the roundabouts oh let me get to that so
okay so you prepared I didn't I got out
of the car I walked around I got in the
driver's seat and to the left of the
steering wheel which is the middle of
the car crazy right there a little
sticker and it says keep left like
somebody put a sticker on there keep
left I'm like okay okay it's that
simple it's just that simple scary and
then I'm like and every time I get in a
rental car in America it takes me at
least 15 minutes to put that thing in
drive I'm just going to say it you know
you got to you got to connect your phone
with the the the car play and you got to
make sure that Works cuz you want the
GPS to be there you don't want to be
fiddle farting with that or the music
and then there you go you got to get
better at the hand farts if you're going
to try to punctuate my stories with
them I'm trying to fiddle fart you know
you got to you got to adjust the mirrors
you got to know where the emergency
break is you got to know how to adjust
everything so that you're not fiddle
farting around once you get on the road
right and now so I did all of that and
then it was like there was an extra beat
like okay I'm putting it in Drive even
putting it in Drive with your other hand
not easy it's weird it was uh it was
like I couldn't do it it's like it's
like it's like writing a letter with
your with your with with your off hand
well not quite but yeah or just writing
a letter cuz nobody does that anymore
it's like oh
awkward I put it in drive and I start to
ease out man I mean the spatial spatial
just identity of the car is so difficult
every and I'm you know I'm driving to
get out of out of an airport this is
like the worst it's it's like the start
is an obstacle course I mean there's
more pedestrians walk around everywhere
there than anywhere else and and people
who don't know where they're going and
who are experiencing the same thing that
I'm experiencing a bunch of Americans
getting into cars that are going the
wrong way the majority of the earth
drives on the same side as
us so it's not just Americans who are
figuring this crap out what is what is
the breakdown of that it's just a
British thing and then they're the the
British colonies but they did a I mean
they did a lot of uh colonizing Yeah
well yeah so I don't like what is the
percentage breakdown of that Jamie of
what what percentage of the world drives
on the right side of the road and the
left side of the road let's see here it
looks like it doesn't give me a
percentage but it say around 30% of the
world drives on the left okay well
that's still the minority yeah so I
didn't know it was that that 70% of the
world 70% of the people going through
there let's just say if this going to
work out cuz I guess all of South
America drives on the right side of the
road yeah I
decided you know I'm just going to I'm
going to get in behind somebody and I'm
going to take it slow and everything was
okay you know once you got on a split
Lane Road it was like two lanes in a
median and the two lanes and then it
really just came about like okay I want
to go slow and I I want to really Pace
myself
and I don't want to make my family more
nervous than they already are and should
be what did you find to be the most
challenging thing staying in the far
left lane when I wanted to be
slow and then after a while not being
lulled into getting back into the right
lane to go slow and then when later when
I'm on a two-lane road not being lulled
into the fact that that right lane is
oncoming traffic and not the fast lane
cuz the first that was the first thing I
was introduced to split split Lane
Highway
um it then we get out into the country
because we were staying out uh outside
of Auckland in like f first of all this
the most bucolic scenery in the the
central part of the northern island is
just like Rolling Green Hills with sheep
and cows all over them that and then an
occasional house mhm just not a lot more
than that absolutely beautiful even if
it is raining a lot more than they said
it would which made it a little bit
depressing at first
um there are once you get out of the
city there are no stop lights there are
no stop signs there are just what I call
yield signs but they they look like a
yield sign and they just say make way
and what I interpreted that to mean
was I'm coming through make way way I
didn't stop for anything but I'm pretty
sure I would have yielded in a
roundabout if somebody was curving
around the roundabouts when you're ran
on them about the opposite way are it's
pretty much a mind screw yeah
um but I was doing okay the key was and
I didn't watch any videos was just go
slow just follow other
people and just trust until you have to
lead and then we had to find a farm
Pharmacy and we went we went back into
town and there was like stress for
finding a pharmacy and like the the
place where the pharmacy was supposed to
be wasn't there and here I'm back into
town and I'm on the left hand side but I
have to turn right and there's cars
coming across and like I think I'm going
to turn right here and now I oh crap no
it's up there and then I'm making a last
second decision to turn right across
traffic into a side street where I think
this Pharmacy is back in Auckland and I
just and I decided to pull out in front
of somebody good and so I gunned
it and make way so then I gunned it and
I turn and then I see that there's a car
in the street that's coming out but then
there's a space to the right of the car
when I'm looking at the car and there's
a space to the left of the car stay left
that's on the sticker stay left and I'm
going and I just don't want to get hit
by the car that I've turned in front of
and I've literally just gunned this
thing and so I Mak an
instinctive
self-preservation decision to just go to
the right of the guy who's stopped okay
uh what The Pedestrian didn't know was
that I was going to do this oh The
Pedestrian is suddenly here there was a
pedestrian walking
behind the car who was stopped that I so
he had crossed and and I should have
gone to the left where The Pedestrian
had just crossed the pedestrian was now
behind the car which he shouldn't have
been tall guy though definitely his
fault and then this probably the 75 time
he's done this I Ken right like I didn't
see him until he was beside me like he
got he like popped back out of the way
and like threw his arms
out and then he kind of faded off he
American just by looking at you oh yeah
oh yeah yeah and I I uh I went another
block and there was no Pharmacy there oh
oh so did you were wrong you were wrong
on every count for nothing but um so I
had to turn around I was like what' your
family say I was like damn I hope that
pedestrian is still not
there uh they weren't Christy just goes
into deep breathing now yeah good for uh
she doesn't say anything anymore
just
she she turns into a tea kettle yeah
after 23 years of marriage she has found
the best way forward link is De
breathing she go her eyes are they her
eyes just kind it's kind of like she's
like she's a Buddha her eyes just get
real thin and just like just air just
seeps out forever that's all she could
do it's just like talk
about and it's a slow head shake and
then she's
like at every other time we stop she's
like go to that side
yeah go to the left you know and I
couldn't there's nothing I could say to
her uh so that was early on in the trip
I got better and better I gained
confidence to the point where I was like
you know I kind of like this side of the
road it's better I think I'll bring this
back to America I definitely love the
fact that like there's there's no stop
signs there's no stop lights it's all
roundabouts and
giveways you don't there's a sense of
momentum m in New Zealand that's like if
you can keep going just keep going and
and you might have to slow down and like
you can do that populated places you
can't do that in it's really nice
Angeles it's really nice I I love that
now the thing that I found the most
challenging and and I had an observer
right because my brother was also
driving and we would sometimes he would
be in the front and sometimes he would
be in the back and I remember we had
been driving for a couple of days and I
was like talking to him and my dad were
behind me and I was like I think I'm
getting the hang of this and they were
like
really yeah they were like well what we
have observed and first of all we were
in
like rural Scotland where I swear the
roads are not as wide as they are in I
mean no they're not they weren't there
either those roads are so tiny they were
they were like your every bridge is
single left
wheel because you're on the right side
of the car like your left wheel is on
the line on the side of the road yes
that's in cuz you don't want to get hit
by the oncoming traffic and you're not
used to accommodating for that side of
the car you're used to accommodating for
this side of the yes so there was a
Christy was like and even Lincoln you
know Lincoln never speaks up about this
stuff like he NE he's never says
anything he's he's a middle child he's
like and then he's and he's not even
he's in the very back of the car like
two rows back alone and all of a sudden
we're you know I just hear him
say Dad you kind of get getting close to
the side of the road a lot yeah yeah
it's it's inevitable um you have this
instinct to like stay away from like you
you have this hyper awareness of
oncoming traffic mhm and so you drift
over there to the left to the point
we're like I'm hitting the rumble strips
a lot if they were rumble strips I I did
that quite a bit I still had a lot of
confidence by the by the end of the
thing Chris and I had a had a a little
getaway one morning where we got a
massage once we had gotten down to uh
Queensland Queen did they start the
massage on the other side of your body
yeah and um we were super relaxed we
came out of that we get back into the
car I'm like we're going to go grab some
food before we go back and I was trying
to
decide I pulled up to the road it was a
two-lane road and I was trying to decide
am I going to go left to this pizza
place am I going to go right to this
other place and I was like making a last
second decision and then that's when you
get into trouble you got to make
completely calculated decisions link
can't be making last minute decisions I
thought you already knew that I had
confidence that's dangerous and so I
decide that I'm going to go
right and I look to my left and there's
no car
coming right in my immediate Lane on the
left but what about to the right because
spoiler alert cars don't come towards
you on the left lane on the media
yeah everyone else is also driving on
the left side of the road not just you
so I looked left there was nobody coming
because no one would ever be coming yep
in that lane and I I start turning right
instinctively again I just reverted and
immediately like someone was laid on the
horn slammed on brakes and I slam on
brakes and it's a it's a really nice
Land Rover which goes past me and then
slams completely on brakes in the road
and stops to my left and gets out the
car stops and there's this moment where
it's like oh he still stopped he still
stopped oh his caution lights are
on he's getting out of his
truck and he's in a huff well yeah he's
an he's an old man he's kind of like
hunched over his his shirts tucked into
his pants and his pants are up really
high that he just in
a
right and
he starts coming up to the nearest side
of the car which is Chrissy's side of
the car and she rolls her window down
now if you remember many years ago the
altercation that I had at the gas
station with the guy that I honked the
horn at who came back in to approach me
he came to Christy's side and I rolled
her window down and I've gotten a lot of
for that ever since because I put
her In Harm's Way by Rolling the window
down so in this instance I remember that
in that moment that's good he I mean he
In fairness the dude was probably 80 he
was walking slow enough that I I started
to develop a plan and as Christy was
rolling down the window I said don't
roll your window down and I started I
hit the button to roll her window up
which froze the window at her eye level
oh and then she looks at me and I was
like ah yeah and she lets go and the
window goes up and then I dressed her to
the guy come over to my side okay all
right now we're talking mhm then I
rolling my window down to eye level I'm
not going to give him a full window I
where he can get his 80-year-old fist
yeah through into my face he would have
to take his 80-year-old fist bring it up
above his shoulder level and then come
down he probably can't do that and then
the the blow would have been it would
have been much more gentle right so I
was Prett I was pretty strategic and you
could trap his hand and I can track his
trap his hand that's right and I see
where you're going with this so I roll
my window down just to eye level
cuz I thought out of respect I don't
want him to have to look at me through a
window out of respect and uh he's
yelling at me before he gets up to the
window but I don't know if it was
because he was old or because of his
accent but I could not understand a word
this dude was
saying you
do okay he's a
smoker and I just waited for a gap in
his tie raade and I
said I'm sorry sir and he then he goes
back into it
again it didn't bring him down a notch
at all cuz you heard your accent yeah
just as I suspected I had no clue what
he was saying again and then uh he I
waited for another Gap and I said yes
sir and then he walked back to his car
which is still in the middle of the road
gets back in and drives off and I look
over at Christie and
she's God bless that woman just just
just release there's a special place in
releasing there's a special place in
heaven for chrisy Neil thank God that I
did not hit that guy thank God thinkk
the thank the Kiwi
Gods it's D I mean you know you're
illustrating man it's dangerous it's
dangerous to just let somebody do that
like I I'm actually surprised I'm not
surprised that we don't require any sort
of steps in America there should be a
course you do anything in America you
get the rental car at the airport and
and and you you should have responsible
countries like New Zealand it just feels
like there should be well there should
be something if you're going to rent a
car you have to watch this video this is
where you're wrong oh come on New
Zealand is not that type of country New
Zealand as I discovered is a fun loving
country of positivity everybody's happy
everybody's barefoot walking around
smiling having a good time the
friendliest people you go into a
pharmacy when you initially you
eventually find one and you know what
happens the pharmacist comes out from
behind the counter Barefoot and and she
starts telling you about all the drugs
that can help whatever type of hay fever
your son is dealing with and spends time
how does she know fever she just knows
it when he walks in he went through the
hay fever door we had a conversation oh
okay that was the thing it's like
they're so freaking helpful there and
friendly you made it sound like she
was uh you know Clairvoyant Clairvoyant
they're Clairvoyant over there um
they're super helpful and they like to
have fun dude this is the place where
bunge jumping was invented now
technically bungee jumping was invented
in vanatu by um you know a woman who
wanted to get away from her horrible
husband and uh she survived the fall the
guy didn't so then women started tying
Vines to their feet and jumping off
towers and they build out of twigs and
then men eventually said hey you women
are looking way too cool doing this so
we're going to take that from you and
now we're going to be the ones to do it
which is what they did right but then um
that I mean there was some kiwi dude who
uh basically turned that into a tourism
sport of bungee jumping which we saw
firsthand over like people jumping off a
bridge and um you could jump into the
you could dip your toe not your toe that
would be jumping backwards your head you
could dip your head into the water if
you wanted to you could dunk your whole
body into the water if you wanted no no
bungies I didn't want to do it because I
want you and me to do that together okay
all right I'm going have to do that for
a Bonafide video If I'm going to do
something that crazy okay but they this
is where they invented it you can also
do it naked there okay if you want to
strip down nude they will allow that I
don't want to put my eye out
officially you supply your I Supply my
own bungee cord for that
one I think they got
[Laughter]
it
uh hand fart
noise the thing that we did do on the um
shot over River um was we and they tell
you you got to do this they invented
this type of boat called a jet boat oh
I've seen the video basically a jet ski
with stadium seating for like River 16
people and you go on a river and do
360s whoa and the these are like tight
gorges and these things can go you can't
drive it though right no no professional
drivers and you just buy a $189 ticket
to sit in there for a 25 minute ride and
it is and we did this as a family and it
was Christy went on this Christy went on
it and she said you know what I'm
excited to go on this cuz you weren't
driving I yeah
I um they can go in like a foot of water
yeah cuz it's jet ski uh propulsion it
it it pulls water in and then shoots out
these jets that are like you know it's
low profile and they go fast and they
can turn on a dime like literally 360
and um you're going through these tight
gorges and they the pilot makes it look
like the front of this thing is going to
hit the side of the gorge and then
you're like you're like skidding out and
it was super thrilling but when we we're
watching other people do it waiting in
the
line
and there's no orientation
there's and I'm pretty sure there was no
waiver to sign now we got in a line they
said anything that's valuable anything
that um you don't want to get wet you
can put in a locker and then you put on
a a you put on a PFD they did they did
put a life vest on you and then you get
in and you sit down and then the pilot
just holds up a placard it's like keep
your arms inside of the
vehicle you don't want to put your arms
on the outside that the difference
between an Aussie accent and a kiwi
accent as far as I can tell is just the
inflection at the end so it keep your
legs inside of the vehicle is my Aussie
accent it's great isn't it my kiwi
accent is keep your legs inside of the
vehicle that's that's the difference
okay it's all that's the only difference
in accents
okay that is the only thing that he told
us there was no seat belt there was a
bar and he said when I do this making a
circular symbol that means you're going
to do a
360 and you might want to hold on at
that
point you know that is the safety
orientation right I mean I mean in
America I guarantee you I'd had to go
through a class and I guar freaking teed
you I'd be wearing a seat belt now maybe
there's something about being a boat and
if it turns over you'd rather get tossed
out I don't know but that's why you
don't wear seat belts in boats
you'd still wear one in America my point
still kind of stands they like to have
fun over there we had a blast Christy
loved that I was like you love that
you're afraid of flying you're afraid of
going in caves you're afraid of a lot of
stuff and I respect that some of this
stuff isn't for
everybody but this was an extreme
boating activity and she's like I just
love being on the water and I'm like
what okay wow this well you got to get a
boat man I got I was like well I got to
get you on a boat
girl yeah and then when we got off Lando
I was like this is the best thing I've
ever done you know you have those
moments where you're like you just where
the kids are just like exuberant about
something like Lily was absolutely
exuberant about uh hobbiton and we when
we we took a tour to Eisen guard we
freaking showed up where the where San's
Tower was of course there's not one
there it's actually a like a
rivered super super picturesque were
they just kind of digitized it yeah
where they digitized it in but like we
literally went went there and so to
watch the kids just be ecstatic about it
Lincoln and I went scuba diving at poor
Knights Islands which is like an amazing
scuba diving experience like scuba
diving scuba diving with these rays and
lots of fish and uh how Co was water
these little it was it was about the
same is as he would wear like a 7 mil
wet suit um he had a head cold leading
up to it IID convince him that listen
you're probably just going to have to
snorkel you're not going to be able to
go cuz you're not going to be able to
clear uh to equalize but he was able to
and he was able to go and it was just
like to for each kid that like have
their moment and for christe to have her
boat moment and you know it's like and
then you as a dad the thing that I
started doing was like looking at the
moments where the kids were deciding to
take photos like that's telling you know
it's like when they feel like
something's photo worthy so it's it was
nice to see each of them kind of pick
their moments and Lando was the uh was
the was the jetbat but they they do they
do love have to have fun down there and
they want you to jump off of stuff um
the most thrilling thing for me was we
went to White Tomo caves y Tomo I don't
know how wao
went um and so we we put on wet suits we
got an tubes and we hike down into caves
where there's like water rushing through
it and we like inter
tubed into the
darkness and saw
gloworms on the ceiling when like we
killed our headlamps this is like these
are real 2 and 1 half
hours yes these are glow worms are real
gloworms are real and it was like how
big are they you're they're really small
and you're they you kill off all the
lights and you're like drifting in this
pitch black cave River
stream and it just looks like
constellations I mean it was that was my
favorite thing because it was so
otherworldly and unlike anything I had
ever done like caves are so cool and
like there were certain points where
there would be like waterfalls where you
had to line up and put your back to the
waterfall with the inner tube around
your but and jump backwards into
darkness and land and like 2 m is pretty
fall far to jump backwards my height
yeah so we we jumped off of a couple of
waterfalls one that was that tall how
cold was that water uh that was colder
that was it was probably so they 60 oh
yeah yeah and um that was thrilling and
the gloworms as it turns out are just
maggots they're just fow maggots they're
they're fly
larvae that poop out a glowy substance
that is a lure for the stuff that they
eat like little flies and stuff insects
to go in there and they go towards the
the glowy thing but then they've dropped
another string like a silk string and
they get catch them they catch them in
that and then they slurp them up and
they eat them and they eat these things
until they get enough strength to go
into a cocoon and then they they take
that strength of eating that stuff they
make a cocoon and then they come out the
other side as a male or female fly and
then they just they get together you
really listen to the T guide all the and
then they they mate and then the male
dies because he doesn't have any more
energy oh go you know cuz you know how
much energy it takes yeah it does
everything you got especially on the
ceiling and then the female takes the
energy she's got and she She lays like a
whole slurry of eggs up there on the
ceiling and then the first and then she
dies and then the first one that
hatches eats all the other ones before
they hatch so that he can get enough
energy to poop out some glow and
start the whole freaking process over
again what is what is the point of
life all of the beauty of nature is for
sex or death it's for perpetuation
they don't even get enough energy when
they turn into flies to to develop eyes
or mouths they cannot see or
eat all they can do is screw and
die there are worth
things would you rather only be able to
eat or only be able to screw and it was
beautiful ask a worm it was the most
beautiful thing I've ever seen in a
cave yeah we had a wonderful time it was
probably the best trip I've ever been on
wow yeah so it's better than
Australia it was action-packed and um it
was more catered towards actual just the
enjoyment part whereas when we were in
Australia we were also touring and not
that that isn't incredibly enjoyable but
it's work at the same time right in the
activities we did like hobbiton was one
of a kind the gloworm cave was one of a
kind the scuba location one of a kind
and then like all of the other Lord of
the Ring stuff was really amazing so
like you recommend it I I loved it I
love it I want to go back I would
definitely go back to
Queenstown I loved it there it was
beautiful I'd like to visit Wellington
didn't get to go there well I didn't go
to New Zealand no you didn't or old
Zealand I went to North
Carolina that's okay um I told you that
I wanted to have a Stak
that was the plan we were going to go to
North Carolina for a few days and then
come back to LA and you said well you
can tell them treat it like a tourist
would treat the city well that's a great
plan until your son gets the
flu yeah and uh lock getting the
flu really put a damper on the family
plans um what were we going to do walk
around Hollywood Boulevard no well we
ended up going we like we went to like
I'd never been to the gy Villa oh yeah
uh which is very cool we that we did do
that
um we were going to do um that light
show thing at disanzo but like actually
that that night it rained that's why we
didn't go that was before
Christmas but we had you know we went to
a couple of restaurants and uh the like
the Lakers Clippers game that we went to
last night was the last thing to do
during the break or whatever but the big
plan that we had was to have and this is
Jesse's idea and I kind of was reluctant
but I ended up going along with it was
to have a New Year's party a New Year's
Eve party and a big one right well it
started as let's have some friends over
and then she then it turned into well
let's invite you know let's invite this
person let's invite this person and then
it was like a last minute thing there's
a certain type of friend that's the
threshold friend that if you think about
inviting them then all of a sudden the
floodgates open right and it was you
don't tell them that that type two weeks
before this announcement comes out two
weeks before New Year's Eve so this is
basically if you don't have
plans long story
short when lock got the flu he was still
pretty much in the throws of it at that
time and we were like well we might get
the flu maybe we've got the flu and we
don't know that we've got the flu yet we
don't need invite a bunch of people to
our house to all get the flu on for the
beginning of the year so we uh actually
rescheduled the party so now you can
come yes it's uh Saturday oh
yeah um oh okay you're invited oh thank
you you're probably already your your
family via your wife probably already
knows this okay um I kind of thought I'd
be snowboarding but maybe I'll be there
uh well if you're snowboarding it's fine
okay so the
uh but what we ended up doing because as
the date approached and Jesse and I were
not sick and lock was getting better but
we basically already said hey we're not
doing the party um our good friends
Ralph and Heather were like well if you
guys want to come
over uh on New Year's Eve we can hang
out on New Year's Eve just you know just
us and Ralph really wants to cook he's a
good cook he's a great cook and anytime
Ralph says that he wants to cook like
Ralph puts my little chicken sandwich
and paa and all you know the five things
that I've kind of tried to perfect puts
it all to shame because I do like this
big thing that everyone can eat all at
the same time and Ralph was like I'm
doing a CO oh meal let me just show you
one let me just show you one course this
isn't someone's home this is just Ralph
in his kitchen making stuff and then
bringing it to the table wow there
there's three PL stack there and so this
my friend is teetering bacon is no so
this is lobster oh butter poached
Lobster and then on top of it is that's
potatoes he teetering taters and then
some sort of leaks or something and some
sort of beat I don't this is just one of
like seven this man's a
maniac wow and it was just for us and uh
he had the French Laundry cookbook now
just so you understand like this is like
one of the best restaurants in the world
it's the kind of thing that if I were to
look at the French Laundry cookbook I
would be I would be lost immediately and
not able to follow any of the steps
because it requires all this background
culinary knowledge that he just has well
you have to be Swiss um more French and
um he's Swiss though he's
Swiss and it was freaking incredible I
and I was just like I was I kept telling
him I was like Ralph this is um this is
so much better than it needs to be you
know what I'm saying like hey we we
didn't need it to be this excellent of
an experience and then we were all
joking about Ralph you should open a
restaurant and then we realized it would
just be called Ralphs and then we
realized that that's a grocery store and
so it would be confusing and so then we
determined that it would be called
Ralphs and then in parenthesis not the
grocery store the restaurant kind of
undersells it but uh that's good to
lower expectations so anyway better than
it needs to be that was uh that was I
gotta say you know me I like to eat that
was the highlight of my of my break was
the food and specifically the food
provided to be to me by my Swiss friend
Ralph the highlight of New Zealand was
not the food for me you notice I didn't
talk about that at all they call B
Burgers with chicken chicken burgers
they call chicken sandwiches chicken
burgers okay uh I don't love that you
don't tip there it's included in the
well there's no tipping so as nice as
everybody is that means they probably
pay people Fair wages I do think that
that is what happens but I as nice as
everybody was the service was not great
at restaurants this just like people
don't expect it to be that great and
because they're not and I think that the
Tipping thing is part of that was there
any um I know that you were more in like
Adventure mode but when you were
in the cities was they're like tonight
we're going to this nice restaurant yeah
well ate some of the best Indian food
I've ever had I mean it's you know it's
going to sound like I'm talking about
London here I also ate some of the worst
Indian food I've ever had too but it was
just we were out we were outside of town
well yeah I mean it's the best thing
that they have are meat pies and you can
just get them everywhere gas stations
it's it's very similar to Australia we
need that here we need more meat pies
now there's certain you can find a
couple places that'll have a meat pie
but like they have them everywhere like
steak and cheese Venison and Plum you
got good coffee though right like
Australia coffee just like in our
experience in Australia it's especially
melbour like they care about coffee
every sign like when you're driving down
the road there'll be signs for two
things coffee and toilets like they care
about and those things go they go hand
in hand in hand
but as a coffee needer as a coffee
addict like that matters to me like
where am I going to get my next coffee
where's it going to come from you never
have to worry about that in New Zealand
because everybody's constantly worrying
about it and the thing the thing that
gets me about toilets though is that
they call bathrooms toilets I don't like
that H it's like don't what do they call
the toilet the commode they just call it
to I don't know I guess they call it
toilets because I mean it is a toilet
but like and there be signs everywhere
that just say toilets it's like don't
yeah I don't want to think about this I
don't say don't put don't say toilets
just you could say restroom bathroom but
they don't think about it in the same
way no and they say it to you too it's
like toilet they say it they say the
word toilet but it makes more sense how
often do you bathe in the bathroom
restroom that's nice oh a little resit
here a little take a little seat how
often do you rest I saw a guy um at the
the the Getty Villa who came into the
restroom while I was in there and boy
did he rest when he urinated you know
like putting your arm up on the wall
over the urinal and just
going like yeah like getting ready to
nap standing up while you're pissed yeah
what is that about maybe he saw some
really breathtaking art and he was just
you know completely
pooped I think some people when they
release down there it just like it
ripples through everything why you put
your whole like it was like arm on the
wall head into the arm and just
like yes like he was experiencing the
best thing ever and it is pleasurable to
you were jealous but I don't want to be
touching no why do people when they're
at a water fountain
like sule people like they they like
push and then they'll just like I hav
seen that since grade school
man well go to an airport
let me tell you yeah yeah I don't get on
those water fountains and airports man
all right and that leads me to my wreck
this week uh wreck baby wreck baby first
one of 2024 from I know it's our second
episode but right it's the first one
we've done in 2024 uh never use the
shorter water
fountain cuz more people suck on it
that's your that's my belief that is my
belief that I mean because the kids kids
will suck on a water fountain kids will
suck on a water fountain and if you and
if there's two go to The Higher One M
and then I always do yeah you do so I
guess I'm inle you still look like a
giraffe at a stream yeah so we're back
at it y'all we survived my family
survived see that's what Christie
does slow breath out I love New Zealand
I highly recommend
it um me
too all right let us know hash
earbiscuits what you thinking about all
this remember leave us a review wherever
you listen to this it is very helpful
especially if it's a positive review
especially so if this show means
something to you put it in a review that
would mean something great to us and if
you have a question or a comment just
want to tell something then you can call
the voicemail number at 1888 earpod
one I'll at you next week hi rut and
Link I am stuck in
traffic and I just wanted to say that I
don't think I could get through bumper
to bumper traffic for 40 minutes in a
sane
healthy well- behaved manner at work if
I didn't have ear
biscuits